نبدا المنتصف من الاراضي الفلسطينيه حيث
اندلعت مواجهات بين قوات الاحتلال
وفلسطينيين في بلده الرام شمال القدس
المحتله هذه المواجهات جاءت بعد ان اقتحمت
قوت الاحتلال البلده عقبه الشيعي شهيدا
قتلته قوات الاحتلال خلال مواجهه امس
اذا هذه الصور التي نشاهدها مباشره على
الشاشه تاتينا من بلده رام هذه البلده
التي تشهد منىوشات او مواجهات بين القوات
الاسرائيليه
وفلسطينيين وكانت هذه القريه قد شيعت في
وقت سابق جثمان الشهيد يوسف محيسن التي
استشهد امس بنيران قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في قريه الراما
[موسيقى]
هذا وافاد مراسل الجزيره ان الجيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي دفع بكتيبه من لواء
المظليين الى الضفه الغربيه وذلك بهدف
تعزيز وجوده العسكري وتدابيره
وستنتشر الكتيبه في مناطق التماس بين
الضفه الغربيه المحتله واسرائيل لمنع اي
عمليات فلسطينيه قد تاتي رد على التصعيد
الاسرائيلي الاخير في جنينه كما رفعت حاله
التاهب في القدس المحتله وضواحيها خصوصا
المناطق التي شهدت مواجهات في الايام
الاخيره
انضم الينا من جبل الزيتون في القدس
نبدا عن المواجهات المحتدمه في قريه الرام
والمعلومات المتوفره لديك
كما يبدو في ضاحيه الرام بين الفلسطينيين
وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي نحن نتحدث عن
احد ضواحي القدس المحتله الواقعه الى شمال
المدينه هذه الضاحيه التي عازلها جدار
الفصل في مطلعي سنوات 2000 وهي اصبحت
معزوله عن مدينه القدس تماما
الفلسطينيون خرجوا في ساعات الصباح لتشييع
جثمان الشهيد يوسف المحيسن الذي استشهد
يوم امس برصاصه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
اشتباكات شهدتها في ساعات العصر
وبعد انتهاء التشييع خرج الفلسطينيون في
مظاهرات غضب واشتبكوا مع قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي التي كانت قد عززت وجودها
العسكري في منطقه الرام وكذلك في معظم
ضواحي مدينه القدس تحسبا من وقوعه مثل هذه
المواجهات عقبه انتهاء صلاه الجمعه شرطه
الاحتلال اسرائيلي عززت من وجودها واعلنت
عن رفع حاله التاهل في صفوفها ليس فقط في
البلده القديمه انما ايضا في ضواحي القدس
التي شهدت في الايام القليله الماضيه
مواجهات عنيفه بين الفلسطينيين وقوات
الاحتلال تحديدا هذه المواجهات التي
تصاعدت في عقاب اقتحام الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لمخيم شعفاط وهدم منزل الشهيد
عدي التميمي اذا الانذار تتجه نحو همم
ضاحيه الرام التي يحدث فيها او يحتضن فيها
هذه المواجهات بين الفلسطينيين وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي كانت عزيزه ايضا من وجودها هذا
الصباح في البلده القديمه تحديدا عند
المداخل المؤديه الى البلده القديمه
والابواب المؤديه الى باحات المسجد الاقصى
المبارك تحسبا من وقوع اي مواجهات او اي
طارئ عقب صلاه الجمعه حوالي 60,000 مصلا
الدو صلاه الجمعه اليوم في باحات المسجد
الاقصى المبارك وجموع المصلين تفرقوا
بهدوء وسلام عقب انتهاء الصلاه لكن المئات
شاركوا بعد انتهاء الصلاه في مسيره كبيره
جابت الباحات للتمديد بسياسات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وما سموها جرائم الاحتلال
والمجزره تحديدا التي ارتكبت في مخيم جنين
صباح امس الخميس هذا عن ذلك جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عزيزا من وجوده العسكري ومن
تدابيره العسكريه في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله حيث اعلن عن الدفعي بكتيبه من
لواء المظليين وهي من الوحدات الاسرائيلي
هذه الكتيبه سوف تنتشر على خط التماس في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله بين الضفه الغربيه
المحتله واسرائيل والمهم الرئيسيه الممكن
اليها بحسب التقديرات هي منع اي عمليه
تسلل لفلسطين من داخل الضفه الغربيه الى
قلب المدن الاسرائيليه وتنفيذي عمليات
المسلحه همم في داخلها وهذه الكتيبه ستكون
عمتها تعزيز التدابير الامنيه تحديدا على
خط التماس وفي المناطق في المناطق الجدار
على الضفه الغربيه المحتله تحديدا عند
الفجوات في هذا الجدار الاوضاع الامنيه
ككل متفجره ميدانيا في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله هنالك العديد من مناطق التماس
والاحتكاك التي تشهد في الساعه الاخيره
مواجهات بين الفلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال
هنالك حاله من الغضب الشديد وحاله من
الحداد بطبيعه الحال في كافه ارجاء الضفه
الغربيه المحتله بما فيها القدس وتمديد
همم من كافه فصائل العمل الفلسطيني على ما
يسموها الجرائم الفلسطينيه بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني وتحديدا ااه الجريمه التي رتبت
بالامس في مخيم جنين ولا ترتقى فيها 10
شهداء من ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني تبقى اذا
هذه الحاله الامنيه على اشدها في داله
سينما وان رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو
كان اجتمع بالامس كبار قاده الاجهزه
الامنيه واجر تقييما للوضع الامني تقرر
فيه ابقاء القوات الاسرائيليه سواء كان
ذلك في الضفه الغربيه المحتله او القدس
وحتى على تخوض قطاع غزه على اهبه
الاستعداد القصوى على الاقل لمده اسبوع
واحد لكن الرسائل التي خرجت فداء من هذا
الاجتماع كانت رساله تقول بان اسرائيل لا
تجرح نحو التصعيد ولا ترغب بالتصيد لكن
هذا التصعيد الميداني فدا ياتي في ظل ايضا
حراك دبلوماسي وسياسي رسيما مع وصول
المدير همم دائره المخابرات المركزيه
الامريكيه الى اسرائيل رغم ان هذه
الزياره كان مخططا لها همم من قبل لكن
الزياره تاتي في خضم هذا التصعيد الكبير
الذي تشهده الاراضي الفلسطينيه وما من شان
فيه ان هذا التصعيد سوف يسيطر ويؤثر ويخيم
على لقاءات همم مدير المخابرات الامريكيه
مع المسؤولين نعم
والفلسطينيين رغم ان اسرائيل كانت تريد من
ان تركز في هذه الزياره فقط على الملف
النووي الايراني وتبيعاته وهذا التصعيد
ايضا فداء ياتي مع اقتراب موعد وصولي وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انطونيو بلينك الى
اسبانيا
مطلع الاسبوع القادم شكرا القدس